a las manos y francia e italia fueron un
claro apoyo a la concesión de la
estatus de país candidato
en la union europea ucrania lohan de eso
el lider y del 3er pais semanal macron
olaf sholes mario dragones pregunta si oi
el brien capital esta desplazado alto
sabe exactamente París para seguir adelante
conecta pais que cabe un dedo en uno
guerra con rusia de idea si pero el mar
y tiene en la reunión con el
el presidente lo cuidó además poco
de ade que los países europeos
precisamente para manifestarse arriba y está
y con sesion implicando riaa tambien
es el comentario del camino de ucrania sia
la entrada y en el club europeo yo tambien
también te metes en eso
Italia, Francia y España en la carretera principal
economía de mi europeo es uno
momento en que se pone de pie y disputa el
presidente francés manuel macron
también de lo que hay disponible
enviando el ejército de masas a ucrania
respondiendo a un kiev hasta petición
sobras de demasiado ruso si en el
región de la base del don en el este del cráneo